hi everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is the
Ingram angle thank you as always for
being with us
tonight yes we're really winning that's
the focus of tonight's
angle we're going to win we're going win
we're going to win you're going to lose
you're going to lose you stink you're
going to
leave ha got
him now even the newspaper that spent
what the past seven years trying to tear
apart Donald Trump is beginning to see
the writing on the wall now the Colorado
Supreme Court decision to strike him
from the primary ballot was a bridge too
far even for judicial activists senior
writer Ruth Marcus considered one of the
Washington post's most senior and really
well-respected writers put it bluntly
the best outcome for the court and the
country would be for a unanimous Court
to clear the way for Trump to run look
they know Trump is going to win the case
from the Colorado Supreme Court and that
any other outcome would set a match to
all already freeing National fabric I
made that point last night and even the
Uber liberal website I love this slate
says the case should be reversed
90 but that's the only the only latest I
think of what will end up being a series
of wins for America's Constitution for
our prosperity Security even for our
culture and mean this from the bottom of
my heart I've never been more optimistic
about America's prospects America's
future than I am
today but unlike a president whose party
believes that America is intrinsically
racist and sexist we don't need to
pretend to be optimistic and pretend to
love the country we are optimistic and
we do love this country no wonder we're
winning and they're losing now their
Embrace of economic socialism neomarxism
wokeism and globalism it's proving to be
a political and practical disaster a
growing consensus of Americans and I'm
talking about white black brown Asian
men and women younger and older voters
are rejecting the policies and the ideas
of Democrats in the far-left money has
has been a little bit tighter things
have gotten a lot expensive more
expensive actually everything is going
up so much so it's kind of reduce my
spending amount this year this is the
worst I've ever seen it and I've been
through I was here through the drug
epidemic I was here it wasn't as bad as
it is now DC is under siege and uh we
need
help now which side do you want to be on
the side that believes in strong Borders
or the side that believes scenes like
this are acceptable are you on the side
that believes that energy Independence
means freedom or on the side that wants
to ban your gas car your gas
stove how about the side that wants to
preserve history or do you want to be on
the side that wants to tear it all down
melt statues and furnaces and put up
monuments to George
Floyd the side that believes in hard
work and Merit or the side that believes
in firsts that firsts somehow matter
more do you want to be on the side that
believes that men or men and women or
women or the side that wants to protect
children or do you want to be with the
people who want to confuse children and
panders to those who celebrate
mutilating their sexual organs to
parents of transgendered children
affirming your child's identity one of
the most powerful things you can do to
keep them safe and healthy to parents
and children alike please ask for help
and know this you're so brave you belong
and we have your
back we're going to win our ideas are
better and their ideas are proven
failures now this is why Joe Biden
despite getting help from the richest
sectors of society is spiraling downward
after 1,66 long days in office this is
where Joe Biden sits in comparison to
other US presidents lower than all of
them at
38.9% no matter what they've done to try
to convince people for instance that
bomic it's really working listen to us
or that the border is secure there's no
crisis here or that Ukraine is right on
the verge right on the verge of winning
just give us another 50 billion or that
Trump's Hitler and Trump's never going
to leave office if elected none of it is
working none of it Democrats spent all
their time arguing that Trump's a threat
to democracy while they themselves seem
very threatened by next year's
Democratic process the New York Times
noting that once again Democrats find
themselves looking toward American
institutions to stop Mr Trump whom they
view as a mortal threat to democracy for
many this is the kicker for many it may
be more pleasant to think about a
Judicial endgame that stops Mr Trump
than envisioning the slog of next year's
likely rematch against President
Biden now the slog of next year's
rematch they don't even realize that
they're proving our point the great
Defenders of democracy believe that
campaigning you know actually winning
over voters is a burden and in a sense
for them I guess with his record it
is but beyond trump our bench is very
strong Governors like Ronda santis Kim
Reynolds of Iowa Glenn yunan in Virginia
Greg Abbott Texas Bill Lee Tennessee
Christine Gomes South Dakota Tate Reeves
and Mississippi many more that is a very
strong bench with a real track record of
success but who do the Democrats have
what the squad going to dine out on them
Nome he couldn't beat Ronda santis in a
debate Kathy
hokel oh JB pritsker he'll try to buy
his way into office
I will take those matchups any day of
the week against any of our people in
the future now we haven't even mentioned
Josh Holly JD Vance Elise stonic all
very strong voices for the
future and it's not just on those
economic issues that we've talked about
so much in the past year that we're
seeing growing
support social conservatism is also on
the rise while liberalism is waning that
my friends is great
news really when I thought about I
thought about writing this as my last uh
angle for the year really it's it's ever
since the 2008 financial crisis and the
rise of Obama what that meant that many
on the right and sometimes I have felt
this way have been a little bit on the
defensive at times it's been painful for
all of us to see the radical changes
pushed by the left and the weakness an
utter weakness of so many who should
have fought back harder and pushed back
harder
but now time to push away that pess
pessimism because the momentum is on our
side the left has gone way too far you
know I like to say they've gone so far
left they've left America and its
supporters in the establishment they
have no nothing left I think but what
threats intimidation and shaky old Joe
Biden so now is the time for everyone
and I mean everyone on our side to be
unfappable be courageous to go full
throttle and take the successful
policies that are already working in
places like Florida and Texas to all 50
states and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else